hey youtubers is charlie so a big teaser
just dropped for the Game of Thrones
telltale games so this video is gonna be
all about that for those that don't know
about it I'll just explain what the game
is about then what the teaser was and
how it's all going to fit in the
expanded Song of Ice and Fire universe
and even though this isn't like a
dedicated book or show video the
giveaway still running so all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment below so important
stuff first if you haven't heard about
it Telltale Games is making a narrative
game based on Song of Ice and Fire it's
going to be a series of stories meaning
instead of like a linear JRPG like final
fantasy that releases sequels the game
of thrones game will have seasons inside
each season new content or patches will
be released in the form of episodes just
furthering the story like new chapters
in a book so if you think about it in
terms of the books just think of each
season of the game as being one of the
books that's not how it's going to go
though that's going to pick up around
book 5 in the story but seasons of the
telltale game will be released about
once a year obviously way more often
than George RR Martin's novels within
each season though they'll be like four
to five episodes just like during the
walking dead game so imagine if George
are Martin release twins a winter like
four chapters at a time over the course
of a year that's basically like how the
narrative of the game is going to
progress the cool thing is is that each
of those episodes it's released every
one to two months so you don't have to
wait that long before more story gets
released even if you haven't played it
most of you are probably familiar with a
Walking Dead telltale Game the game of
thrones one is going to be pretty much
exactly like that the way it works
they're actually getting ready to
release season three of The Walking Dead
game and since I'm going to be doing
weekly walking dead episode videos when
the TV show starts again I might give
out steam codes for that in addition to
the Game of Thrones Game both games will
have the exact same mechanics so if you
want to prepare for the Game of Thrones
give just play the walking dead game a
lot of you asked how the game is going
to fit into the Canon of the series
it'll basically share the same
relationship that the book of the show
have it'll take characters from the
novels and write a story arc that
loosely follows the direction of the
books in reality though like when we're
all sitting down playing it it's going
to feel more like a big side story like
a really big side story you know how
george RR martin tease he might write an
eighth novel after a dream of spring
just so he has more room for all those
side characters think of the telltale
Game is like that just one
giant side story right now the game is
still on alpha like they're not even in
beta yet they're basically still writing
what the story is going to be they hired
the guy that wrote destiny so it's
actually gonna be really interesting
george RR martin was so upset with the
quality of previous game of thrones
games that he actually personally picked
telltale games to develop this game he's
not going to be writing any of the
stories for the game but he does have
his inner circle consulting because of
the way telltale games narratives work
they basically have the
choose-your-own-adventure model
decisions you make in Episode one of the
game will affect the story in later
episodes which is actually probably one
of the most exciting things so given
prior knowledge of Song of Ice and Fire
you might have a few slight advantages
into knowing where to put characters but
the story that they do right is going to
be unique it won't be completely based
on winds of winter it's not like the
show thing where george r martin has
basically explained everything to the
game people it'll take a couple threads
based on where the novels are right now
and then just go in its own direction
like i said though from a development
standpoint the game is still an alpha
it's not open to beta testers yet early
release date estimates are december 2014
like december this year there haven't
been any major delay announcement so
until we hear otherwise just plan on a
December release and remember each new
episode patch comes every one to two
months so we should have at least
episode two or three before season five
game of thrones starts for those of you
suffering from Game of Thrones
withdrawal during the offseason the game
will be your drug of choice like you
will want to buy this book readers will
totally enjoy it just because of the
story based element which like I said
George RR Martin's camp does have a
certain amount of input in and the
people that only watch the show will
totally love it just for including
elements from the show and it would be
totally awesome if characters from the
show voiced their characters in the game
but just like walking dead just like
that game I don't think they're going to
have a lot of the actors from the show
in it if you haven't played The Walking
Dead game they basically focus on a
different group of characters like they
created a unique protagonist in
Clementine so next big question what
characters are they going to include in
the video game right now the teaser they
released features in ahsha Greyjoy quote
and house Forrester it was this one card
with the quote it's not even a trailer
they released it because pax is going on
right now but they haven't shown off any
gameplay yet so obviously because it
includes an Asha Greyjoy quote and
house Forrester in that tease is pretty
clear that it's going to focus around
these characters and when I say ah
Shakira joy I mean you know Ironborn
Ironborn house Forrester characters if
you're not familiar with house Forrester
they're basically up near Winterfell in
the north the good thing about this is
there jumping off would point is
Deepwood Motte from book 5 from disk
with dragons so in order to explain this
a little bit better i'm not to get into
spoiler so i will include like a little
spoiler tag so you can just skip forward
of the video till you don't see the tag
anymore or just turn the volume down but
I'll wait just a sec okay here we go
house Forrester only appears in book
five when lady Sybil Stannis's queen
provides Scouts from their house 28
Stannis's army as they march through the
wolf's wood from Deepwood Motte
Winterfell Stannis is marching on
Winterfell to deal with the Bolton's you
know that's the big spoiler obviously
that's a huge event it's going to be
happening winter winter no known member
of house Forrester has appeared in the
books on the show yet no big characters
but presumably they'll be featured more
in winds of winter the iron from ice
quote is spoken by asha Greyjoy's if you
remember she became a captive of Stannis
at Deepwood Motte along with her
ironborn soldiers so all these things
basically point to the story taking
place in the wolf's would because in The
Walking Dead game Clementine was a brand
new character it's likely the tell-tale
will do the exact same thing and create
a new character inside house Forrester
or like an Ironborn character to be the
protagonist someone that's new but fits
inside the pre-established cannon like I
said the battle for Winterfell is a
winter winter thing so no word on
whether or not season one of the video
game will go that far but the story is
basically going to focus on the
happenings between Deepwood Motte and
Winterfell okay it's so spoilers over so
in addition to the Game of Thrones bonus
videos I'm already doing I'm going to
try and get my video game channel up and
running by the end of the year so that I
can do video game videos you know for
this telltale Game I'm almost done
moving to my apartment so you know
hopefully in the next couple of months
I'll have that gaming channel Charlie's
dreams up and running there is a link on
my homepage on my YouTube homepage to
that channel but i'll add one in the
description too if you've never seen it
before like i said though the game's not
coming till december i might be able to
get a beta copy before then to do some
preview videos but i'll keep you guys
posted as things get figured out it's
probably going to be a little while
before any footage surfaces i will be
doing a Q&A
for this tonight so please submit all
your questions they don't have to just
be about the video game but you can
click here to get that video I live
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here to learn all about the
religions in the gods and the sacrifice
on fire thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives